so this is a two-point argument here
that we the last 15 minutes we went into
we'll change the topic here in a second
one of the arguments is is meta coming
yes is it going away i don't think so
you may say it's going i don't think
it's going away if it's not going away
this is uh uh not going to be
the same as it's been in the last 20
years because meta is a full argument
against this
and nft ethereum bitcoin all of that is
going to be an argument for
why you ought to be there because if you
want to buy a token the only we can buy
token 50 of the time is through ethereum
right right if you want to get in there
if you want to buy an nft if you want to
do this you know i was just at art basel
conference this last week you guys went
to the art pass basket you know how it
was so
you're walking around and you're looking
at greensboro north carolina well you
crushed it i mean i you know some of the
guys were sending me messages but uh
uh but going back to it so i was at art
basel and i'm walking i'm looking out
these pictures okay some of the stuff
was freaking strange that's art i love
it right
but
i don't know if you saw that there was
like 10 galleries that were selling nft
art
and that's all it was did you talk to
perez you know there was he had comments
that that went
kind of george yeah i mean it went he
got like a lot of heat because
he was really upset about this because
he said art is an experience
you know it's kind of like i've been out
to marvel texas to see the donald judd
foundation and it's really a trip
everyone should should make i mean jeff
gunlock is the one that told me about
visiting there he's like you've got to
visit there it's this dan flavin light
exhibits and all these things you can't
see them anywhere else see them anywhere
else okay think about what gunlock told
me you can't see them anywhere else you
go to the jud foundation no cameras not
because they don't want you to
photograph the art because donald judd
said if you're looking at the aperture
of a camera you're not using your eyes
and the art affects your eyes because
you look at the art you have an
experience and i want you to have that
experience here you can look at your
camera some other time
perez is saying that he's saying art is
an experience how old is perez
so here's the thing are we transitioning
into a time where the experience is
you've got a rock with two laser eyes
and you flex in the metaverse and if we
are then what you're saying is human
beings now are comfortable
not having individuality which probably
is true but will they ever wake up and
say
my whole entire life is
captured and gone well there's there's
two different arguments that are being
made right here well do you do do you
eventually most people become grumpy old
men okay slowly
and by the way and we have to
uh uh cling on whatever our legacy is
and anything that takes away from our
legacy
we kind of become grumpy so let's just
say whatever that like if you're like do
you know anything about george perez do
you know what pam
it's the perez art museum of miami i
lived across the street from it so like
the guy has a vested interest in typical
art what i'm trying to say is what i'm
trying to say is if you're going there
and the legacy is tied to it he has to
say that yeah but unfortunately i don't
own a single nft not one i don't know
one of those monkeys any and i don't
know none of that stuff right on the
board apes
the apes i don't know if i may
eventually buy one i'm telling you guys
of right now i don't all i'm saying to
you is
a comment like that being made
you know goes back to the movie grumpy
old man so let me say something against
the guy he's a legend i get it but in
that market the argument from nfd is
going to be yeah let me say something
about what eb said that i want to
revisit and you touch on it with the nft
so you talked about essentially the
warren buffett quote about be fearful
when people are greedy
greedy when people are fearful
i was also there a few hours after you
uh this was what was something i was
there with my wife and kids you were
there with four girlfriends
regardless we were checking out art it
was good adrian actually bought a piece
adrian bought a piece in crypto or a
buddy a real piece
but you use digital currency to buy a
real piece of art jackpot right so
here's my point be fearful when people
are greedy so we're there we're checking
out art it's crazy it's expensive we
usually hot tip you go on sunday yeah at
seven o'clock when it ends at eight
and they're selling a piece for five
that money you go for they're selling a
piece for five grand you're like look
it's gonna cost you a thousand bucks and
ship it i'll take it off your hand i'll
give you for thirty two hundred bing
bing bing bi so some guy comes up to me
and he has this like french accent he's
like yes they're good look at this piece
it's we're selling it as an nft and uh
you have to understand they were we're
showing you the experience but then when
you buy it so and i go yeah but you know
what so what's the nfts like yes this is
the wave of the future and you have to
understand and i go yeah but but what's
the nft and and like almost he like lost
his friends action he's like listen bro
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know
i just i'm just trying to sell somebody
oh yeah
so when people are be fearful when
people are greedy that's exactly the
story that this guy's busy saying this
guy he didn't even have an accent by the
time that he confided this reminds me of
the children's story emperor's
guy has no clue
exactly
and they keep they keep telling this guy
no no you look great you look great he's
standing hold on one second
we lost the podcast we lost the feed
what's the reason this time
maybe perez owns the building wow we get
to the bottom of it finally all right
almost back yeah i'm buddies with his
son jp perez
so anyways you were saying so the old
the book
yeah it's bad there's a children's book
the emperor's clothes you know we all
know the story is that the the they're
like no no you look great you should
spend a lot of your treasure to buy this
new fabric and there is no fabric and
he's naked he's naked and he's then he's
all embarrassed in the end and so what
what we're really saying is will there
ever be a moment
when people say
holy crap i mean i actually need
something
that i can put my hand on and the answer
so far has been no so for not and not
for one year or two years
tesla back in the day was saying that he
didn't like the concept of television
because people will think they've gone
to the grand canyon because they've seen
the grand canyon you haven't really seen
the grand canyon you know and it's you
know his whole thing was he wanted to
transport people there that's what you
think technology should have been used
for you know human transport instead of
just you know he thought it was
cheapening like obviously
edison didn't get along but he thought
it was cheap that somebody could take a
digital rendering of something show it
to somebody and then their brain would
interpret it as having been there you
know but
we're going to be able to go
to the grand canyon in the metaverse
we're going to be able to go who wants
to stand in line in disney world
you can go into disney world in the
metaverse and
not have a line and then go up and down
the roller coaster in the metaverse and
i
philosophically i tend to agree with you
i don't like where it's going i think
it's dangerous i think that giving up
personal autonomy for non-stop uh you
know serotonin is stimulating horrible
uh but i i don't know why is it horrible
because now someone can turn it off yeah
it's total control you right now
see all we're talking about is the
upside of it the smartphone's great you
know where you're going all the time you
can pre-order a coffee and make it any
way you want you know but someone can
turn it off no no see this you're saying
that controller can turn out
but
as a user you can also turn it off but
i'm going off the grid real quick this
is what i think has happened in this
conversation this is what i've
we're having two different conversations
at the same time we're having a
conversation about where this thing is
going
and then you're having a conversation
about why it's wrong to go that way i
don't disagree with you but we're
talking about trying to speculate we're
talking about tangible yeah and real you
can do both i i really believe you can
do both i mean that's why i talk about
the platform of the crypto and then the
coins if you understand the platform and
you understand the coins and you want to
make a play into it knowing that you can
do both you can do both but you're going
to
choose i think you're but you're not
getting back
i've kind of got all that i need you're
all in on gold yeah it's not i'm not all
in on gold i mean i have the carbon
credit royalty business is incredible
you know i mean you're planting mangrove
trees you know in southeast asia and
selling the the the carbon capture to
people that fly in air but like right
there though but you're doing carbon
credits carbon credits is basically a
tax for living it's an existence tax
it's just so everything is carbon so i
mean how can you you're worried about
you know the the morality of one thing
and then the other one i'm not worried
about the morality like i think you can
you can play a trend you know and then
you can do something with your own
money i don't think there's anything
more evil and i know that all the
environmentalists and the lefts and they
think i'm a crazy righty and all that
stuff there's nothing more evil in the
world to me than a carbon tax who the
hell gets to tax you for living it's
crazy and people are all for it i mean
take a poll of young people and they say
that's important i mean people are more
interested in that business by the way
than this than the metalla metallo
business you tell someone about 30 years
of gold
no i'm not interested 30 years of
mangrove trees i'm all in i want that
when can i buy that on robinhood i'm
ready right now it's amazing investment
bankers like we'll we'll do a road show
for that we're going public next
next fall they'll set up two weeks of
meetings in the gold business one day
i i i uh um
i don't know you know i'm not uh uh
you will never put me in the box of a
crypto guy would you ever put me you've
been with me for how many no you're not
a critical guy and i'm not a gold guy
but i own both you are a card guy you're
a baseball card guy by the way i own uh
most for me is cards
uh second most would be probably crypto
then it's gold this is what i own okay
but my number one is cards and i'm not
including my investments obviously
that's number one stocks all the other
stuff that's equities is number one but
then number two is this and
and so
for me when i think about this
this is
you know it's it's a different uh it's a
different gig
i think this
i don't think this is gonna the only
thing that this is gonna it's gonna make
this explode is a catastrophic event so
if you think about the triggers
inflation goes up this needs to go up it
didn't work
a a level of uncertainty in the world a
war happens
a a massive you know pandemic happens
this needs to go up
it didn't really work like that so the
triggers have changed in a major way you
know there's speculation in stocks there
is the fed all of a sudden votes
somebody in that's a communist from
russia and she replaces let's just say
powell oh we got to be careful because
we don't know what she's going to do
okay that goes up
but it hasn't so so many things isn't
moving this and so many things are
moving crypto bitcoin ethereum
that they can say c
c c yeah and gold can't say c c c so the
credibility for the gold community in my
opinion has gone down that's yeah
it has and so here here's here's the
thing when you get back to that thing
about the moody family right
you want to buy your hedge when it's
cheap
like everybody wants to buy insurance
the day after the hurricane comes
through right it's really expensive
right and there hasn't been a storm for
years no one wants to buy insurance
that's when you buy the insurance so to
take a one percent hedge right now to
your point is extraordinarily cheap it's
never been cheaper because you have all
the signs of swirling you know clouds in
the air and people are like no i don't
want that so so take the hedge when it's
cheap and then also play
the speculative move like play that move
that's it you're basically saying in
sports you don't just play offense you
don't just play defense you got to play
both sides of the ball so play some d
and then get on your own nobody cares
and so you you can get in there the
ironic part about what you're saying
also man is like nobody clamors for
freedom until they have none of it so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you